would you rather be a turtle or a coyote
probably a turtle because coyotes eat
like raw meats rather eating like plants
so let's move on to round seven round
seven was a quicker game and a happier
results at least for me and I played an
opening which I can't remember the last
time I play this i start with d4 and
like any time i play d4 at least in like
tournament play i always follow up with
Bishop f4 but in this game I play the
Queens gambit Queens gambit is I mean
it's a line that I I sometimes play like
if if I play the English and black plays
e6 I kind of have to go into a Queens
gambit but I decided to play this move
order I was expecting Queens gambit
declined
we actually got exactly what I was
expecting at least for the the first
five or six moves ecigs oh I should note
my my opponent is Peter Gian honest via
master rated just under twenty three
hundred so Knight c3 he plays Bishop e7
there should be seven I think is a more
topical move these days the idea is to
force white to make a decision as I
can't develop the Bishop to g5 like
sometimes after an ayah six submission
will come to to g5 but some delays it
for one move so I play one of the main
lines here it takes take some Bishop f4
this is yeah I mean this has been played
many times before
Magnus nakka nakka Geary etc c6 III or
wait no not e3 there's a another game
going on in our section I think between
Olivier and Keaton Cara where it went
III and then Bishop e6 and stuff
happened by play Queen c2 first idea of
Queen c2 is to stop Bishop f5 and then
okay very soon I want to play e3 so in I
have six III I was actually expecting
him to play Bishop d6 he has had one
game in this previously and he played
Bishop d6 but okay play Knight of 6 so
this is kind of the first move slightly
outside of my preparation but I've
played this position as black so I I
have a general understanding of what the
plans are I play e3 plays a knight bv7
then I played my next move on a slight
misjudgment because I was imagining when
black wants to play Knight h5 and the
first move that came to mind was h3 just
to keep the bishop everything would be
okay but I thought I had a trap here I
played Knight f3 with the impression
that after Knight h5 I would have Knight
takes d5 so I want to pose this as a
question to the chat after 9 h5 is my
takes d5 a good move or a bad move
actually better question Knight takes d5
is a bad move but why is it a bad move
the idea is after it takes Bishop c7 to
trap the Queen so this is my at least it
was my original intention so after
Knight takes d5 what can black do to
punish whites
does anyone have it do if I stumped
everyone when a5 does nothing
Oh extreme DotA yeah extreme DotA I
think knows
what's up
so 1985 is bad because black can just
take and after Bishop c7 yeah it looks
like the Queen's traps but there's
Bishop to b4 check and I'm just down the
piece here I gave away a knight the
Queen that has room to escape so I was a
little bit disappointed in myself and
like after I played 9 f3 I realized that
like he can play Knight h5 and just get
the bishop
get the bishop hair so yeah Bishop
before making moved for the Queen so he
play Knight h5 and then I mean I had a
choice here in between it's considering
actually Bishop e5 castling or Bishop g3
played the most natural move Bishop g3
and even though this came from a Queen's
Gambit I mean there's some similarities
with the London especially after he
takes and this is something we see a lot
in the world in the London with some
some h-file pressure so he plays minus 6
and I Castle I was still feeling pretty
comfortable and yeah I mean white setup
is pretty harmonious as like all the
minor pieces are a reasonable I do have
that half of an h-file
and then somehow things got good really
quickly and then there was actually a
weird moment here he played Bishop g4
and I think he said something I think he
offered a draw but I wasn't entirely
sure and like the last two days when
I've been white in the second game of
the day my opponents have have offered
me early draws like within the first 10
moves and I've was accepting accepting
them because I wasn't happy with with
openings but in this game I I felt like
pretty comfortable and if he did offer
me a draw I still would not have taken
it and especially after Bishop g4 I
think I have a feeling it's a slight
inaccuracy
because i dont think blacc ever wants to
take and at some points I'll relieve the
pin and I'll play 95 tip the bishop so I
was thinking here I mean the bishop does
need to find a square oh maybe it's not
so easy
thinking Bishop e6 but then there's
Knight g5 so yeah maybe blacks positions
already a bit tricky maybe start with
Queen a5 I thinking blacks should just
like somehow find a skirt for the bishop
and Castle mean maybe Bishop d7 looks
very slow I thought I thought can castle
get the King to safety it shouldn't be
so bad there is also castling kingside
which he actually played in the game so
let's go forward this ship g4 played
Bishop d3 h6 and then king b1 been
feingold rule always play king b1 in
this position I think King be one is
slightly multi-purpose if he ever plays
Queen a5 then my knight would not be
fully tied down to a two sometimes I
have maneuvers with this Knight also
sometimes I want to play rook c1 and put
more pressure on the half-woman C file
and also get out of the pin that's
actually what happened
so you Castle kingside and I play rook C
1 so now it looks like I I cast old it
illegally like I've seen beginners
castle like this in like one move it
took a couple extra moves to get this
this configuration so Vikings very safe
here and because it's opposites like
castling
it's just naturally a sharper position
and I thought I had more attacking
resources and also just more defensive
resources to like I felt like blacks
attack is a bit slow here 95 is coming
very
very soon and once the Bishop's hit I
have ideas of like g4 g5 to try and open
the H file so I think the combination of
h6 and castling just gave me a lot of a
lot of potential and I think if if flack
like somehow found the time to castle on
the queenside like King V eights I think
the king is much safer there but of
course when he castles King side he he
does want to like expand and destroy me
and he actually had a game few rounds
earlier a slightly similar situation
like opposites like castling actually
from a London opening and he just
completely demolished White's but of
course it always depends on the position
so he plays c5 and I play 95 hitting the
bishop ignoring stuff I heard ideas of
chief hath says love-hate chess did g5
occur in this game g5 did not occur in
this game there was a I had there was a
point in this game where I was
calculating lines with g5 I was actually
imagining like love-hate chess being
being satisfied if I would get g5 in
there z6f for I'm just the play flows
like very nicely ideas of I think my
main idea is f5 kicked the bishop again
then g4 g5 sacked the pawn and then
played g4 again idea of Queen h2 in
Queen h8 mate and like a good number of
these moves come with tempo so he played
Knight g4 which i think is just a
blunder but I'm not sure what else to do
like it's already very unpleasant for
luck so let's see what happened the game
like g4 now this position there's
actually a very simple forcing sequence
which I think guarantees White's
to win upon I simply take take
f-five this bishop has to take after a
queen takes a five there's no way to
defend d5 so this is a the drawback of
playing c5 I think you played c5 with
good intention it's just I was weakening
to d5
he takes I take d5 still hang man Bishop
to f6 and this is a point like I was
beginning to imagine like okay what if I
just go for a g4 g5 it's not easy to
defend but then I also still wanting to
win this pawn so I began to calculate
and line that I calculated was I think
pretty forcing I just take on d5 I let
him take on d4 and then I play rook t1
now the bishop like even though the
bishops in the center it's so short on
squares
you can't play Bishop f6 because when I
just take twice and all win h6 otherwise
I mean the bishop has to retreat to one
of these squares
I think Bishop b6 was the best move but
he played Bishop c5 after Bishop c5
there's is a like very nice move for
whites which wins on the spots so I'll
actually leave this for the chat white
to move I mean White's position is
already nice like the pieces are in
prime position black is a bit
underdeveloped with the major pieces a
bishop is a bit loose King is a little
bit under fire so white to move try and
find the best move if you're watching on
YouTube in the future
feel free to pause the video and think
yeah okay looks like almost everyone
found it George
288 saying rook takes h2 taking the the
free air now trick h6 it's a nice
aesthetic move threatening mates
black has to take but the 9:06 and I got
mating but I'm also winning McQueen so
happened the game here here king went
back to g8 and then yeah there was no
need to take the Queen just queen g4 and
the game finished so I had a feeling if
we go back the better try in this
position was Bishop b6 I actually spent
like when I took on d5 I was calculating
like pretty long line maybe I'll use
this opportunity to draw arrows so I was
calculating ninety xd5 Bishop takes d4
rook d1 Bishop d6 still rook takes h6
pawn takes h6 Knight f6 King g7 then
after Knight h5 he has King h8 so not
getting mated then I would take the
Queen he would have to take back with
Bishop to defend f6 because otherwise
Queen f6 would just be mates and then I
would have Queen B five check provoking
f6 and then Queen d5 so this is my
calculation from from this position
we're like material-wise it's actually
kind of balanced like it's two rooks for
a queen and pawn but I mean blacks
pieces are really bad be sevens hanging
and I would have ideas okay not of g4 g5
but ideas of f5 and bringing the Knight
to g6 so I wanted to be certain that
like everything was working before I
went for for this but okay none of it
happened because he played Bishop c5 so
just to show that over the board Bishop
e6 takes takes not sure if there is
anything better King h8 takes takes here
Oh Queen d5 is also nice cousin fighting
this and like G sevens a bit weak oh but
I'm also threatening to the rook and g7
so yeah this should just be losing for
luck yeah a rook seeing on the bad try
but then I just went like so many pawns
and it's so hard to stop them from
coming to g6 so um that was how's my
game relatively quick wind pink the game
overall it was like about 90 minutes in
in length so got some time to take some
walk can you show the final position
again yeah I can show the final position
final position was well it's bits from
Henry Lord Vuitton thanks for the bits
so after rook takes h6 the final
position was this Queen g4 and black
black is either getting made a right
away or getting made eventually after
Queen g5 just takes so so yeah again for
the YouTube audience thanks for watching
smash the subscribe button and click the
bell right there's a bell like to get
notifications I think and I'll see you
guys in the future